how do you die man how do you die
because no because I like it you know
when I listen to your acting stuff and I
see you like have these you know like
you get these visions and like you know
and you talk about how like you know
it's them its life as a movie and
there's this thing you know and you how
do you die man cuz it has to be
something neat yeah
you can't die in a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass way
like in a like in a hospital can you I
don't want to I think that like this
cookies and [ __ ] on the table or
something in this [ __ ] yeah
somebody's supposed to be there with you
and they got a call or in the [ __ ]
hallway yeah he died um I think that uh
I you either this is how you go you
either you you're in your bed mm-hmm at
home mm-hmm you just have a malfunction
and pass away if you can't get that
mm-hmm there's no oh he's got he's got
cancer he got take him to a hospital for
[ __ ] to two months and he dies there
I'm not doing that [ __ ] yeah bro don't
do that now uh oh [ __ ] he's on his last
leg I don't ever want anybody saying
that [ __ ] about me right why cuz you
don't want that news to get out or you
know I just don't know I don't want did
that's boring regular [ __ ] yeah I want
to I think honestly a cool way to go hmm
you gotta do something I know but who
knows if I'll be big then you know I
mean who knows if I'll have my if I have
my think it'd be cool to like if
somebody like if somebody poisoned me
like that I like really like if I broke
their heart and then they poisoned me
like some real like Korean [ __ ] yeah you
know what I'm saying or like no Japanese
I guess it would be Japanese I don't
mean to be racist but no it could be
either one it does a lot of Korean no
Korean is a lot a lot of Grenada revenge
yeah yeah yeah let most multi-factor
ever been a movie in made by Koreans or
Japanese that wasn't about revenge yeah
but uh a lot of poison meat - in all
their films there's a lot of food poison
so so yeah so like if I broke somebody's
heart and I probably you already did the
thing that borrow whatever you are it's
you've already done waiting that's
buried you're milling in the distance
you've done it you've done it you've
done the thing that ruins
you're done if I ran for president it's
already over
yeah way yeah me too just cuz a couple
of texts have probably sent 100% now I
could see this maybe you're at a diner
right here in the mountains right your
truck breaks down right and you thought
yet you like and you have a dog in the
back you try can't even [ __ ] serve it
to your dog but it fits the vision right
so you walk out you walk up to this
diner right you get in you call you know
maybe Michael anoche or somebody or
maybe even um you know Chris Pine or
somebody I know him yeah and you call
them and they're like yeah we'll come
help you yeah and you but in the
meantime you're gonna wait you can have
a sandwich right and they don't have
anything on the menu that you like you
know for the walk go figure right but
the lady says that they can make you
something special she says we have a
special of the day and it happens to be
like your favorite food like oh that's
wild so you get it you're sitting there
eating right you take two bites and then
you realize you're poisoning you look in
the distance and the waitress or the
manager is an old flame somebody yep
yeah that's a way to go and I'll tell
you what to you verse and you'd worse I
would 100% respect I'd be scared of [ __ ]
I would cry probably but I would but to
have that gentle conversation where they
sit down and they let you know what
happened and they're like listen i
poisoned you this is it there's nothing
you can do about it you broke my heart
you know and and I loved you and you
really hurt me in in you know 2008 or
whatever it was
yeah and you've lived your whole life
you're 77 and I never got remarried I
never had another I always you were
always a person on my mind and I have to
kill you before I die and that's what I
did and I'm sorry but I had to do that
for me dude tears running down my face
man and I hate the rest of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] before I died too I mean at all
give me a minute you have this special
[ __ ] give it to me I'll ingest it and
all that did I feel like crying right
now man yeah and that's how I'm gonna go
that's how I want to go dude and no
[ __ ] that's how I wanna go and if I
take those last few bites and I feel the
poison swirl my throat up and I look
over at that my dog not my dog whatever
the [ __ ] that thought is sitting in that
truck and
for [ __ ] you know either my opener or
Chris Pine to get there and they dad
died before that I die before that bro
but I'm looking at that dog and I'm
wondering is that dog - that dog not
mine that's the last [ __ ] thought I
have and I'm holding the girl's hand and
she gets it and it's like I'm so sorry
honey
yeah man that's the thing that's a real
way that's the real way bro because that
would mean something at the last moment
you'd be having at least an effect even
if that effect is that you are letting
them have that mode even if it's yeah it
would be something real yeah yeah it's
like you're like this Neil Armstrong for
like real [ __ ] sometimes
man that's just emotional yeah I I yeah
I would go that way I would like to go
that way actually
what would you go into battle to see
maybe going well that's another way with
a sword but not with a gun no no no no
but I don't want to get like all cut up
yeah soft battle maybe like slap battle
he died he died getting slow out a lot
that's West as for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
and you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz it's alarming